so
you
what's going on chat
how's things going
i know this is like spontaneous
like
i know i'm sure a lot of you didn't
expect this
i know i said i was taking a break
and i was i had every intention on
taking a break
but today pretty good you know my my
tooth isn't hurting as much today it's
not really hurting at all
i've been having a lot of issues with
this this toothache but
thursday i go and get get my wisdom
teeth cut out
thursday
is
is the extension date man thursday
everything is fixed
so what's going on chat
what is going on realm
i know i probably won't have a whole lot
of people showing up for this i
originally wanted to stream yesterday
well
yes yes no saturday because it was my
birthday but
i just didn't have a whole
i just didn't have the desire of the
will i don't know what was going on that
day you know obviously we got a little
artillery going on right now what's
going on yeti we're going to talk a
little bit about the games of 2021
talk a little bit about the state of
halo infinite
and the state of gaming in general from
here on out to 2022 2023
and more
and i just want to you know go over a
couple things uh you know maybe even
play some halo infinite while we do it i
don't know yet i don't know depends how
i feel because last time i played halo
infinite on stream i got murdered
what's going on gaming xtc
x xbox that was a mouthful pause
so what what's the chat doing man what
what are you guys doing i feel like
i ain't been on the stream consistently
in a minute i come on iop
um i want to i i tried to stay
on the whole last episode of iop but
yeah i'm kind of
kind of in a relationship now and i had
obligations
i made promises man i made promises i
had to
to
to do some stuff so you know but but you
know i'm going to do a better job on
separating that life with
the youtube life if that makes sense to
you guys
you know because i gotta have a balance
i gotta have a balance i and
i'm gonna get a balance man so let me
this new windows 11 got some crazy stuff
going on i gotta
delete some of this
they
are tripping
shout out to flame with the two dollar
super hey addict hope you have a good
holiday brother uh my holiday
it's about what it is every day man
about what it is every day but i
appreciate the super chat
i appreciate it
you know what
let me
okay that's not you know why did you
recommend ascent that game was hot trash
i don't remember me recommending
anything name dissent i think if i
remember correctly i remember me talking
mad snap about ascent
so maybe you may be
gaming x tc you're referring to addict
with a c
and not adequate for t
because we've we've established
gaming
xtc
that there are difference
there's a difference between attic or
facing addict with a t
we we got this man we got this
we got this
so me
let's
what's going on fawn so let's
i know
this is spontaneous i know i said i
wouldn't make another one i know i said
i was shutting down the attic show for
the rest of the year but here we are
making me a damn liar
so
let's talk about games of
2021.
you know we we've actually
look i've been very vocal about saying
that
games of 2021
has been kind of a letdown and i'm not
saying like
the games have sucked because i don't
think they've sucked i think we've had
really solid games this year
and i think that
i don't know who it was oh it definitely
wasn't me
uh because when i tried to review that
game
it was it it ran like it ran really bad
you know i'm sure it's fixed by now but
i don't really give
second chances when it comes to
performance you know there's certain
games that i have
what are two like evil attic yes there's
two addicts there's two addicts and you
guys know this there's two addicts
you know we we uh
we we go over and over the two addicts
there's adequate for c
an adequate fatigue
you got what you're on pc
um
no i have it on xbox though hold on let
me look
let me look
let's see
let's see here
i'm pretty sure i have it on xbox
let me move this over here
uh
let's look let's look chat i think i
have it on xbox
but it would be like on the the own
games see look
753 games
i have
753 games and i still have no idea
what to buy
i know that's a huge issue and i know i
shouldn't really have that kind of
mindset but i do have a hard time
finding stuff to play i do
i need i need to do better
we need to do better
what's your w
what's your
three and it looks like i have witcher 2
i don't know how that happened but i
have it
maybe game pass or something i don't
know i don't know if it's on game pass
but it is what it is
you know
light mode why do you guys always clown
on my light mode
like you guys are the most ridiculous
people when it comes to the light mode
i've ever seen in my life you guys are
always like addict why do you have light
mode why does it matter to you guys
explain to me why it matters someone in
the chat tell me why
it affects you so much and it's not just
you flame this there's countless people
that bring up my light mode on xbox and
i gotta know what you guys
are referring to and if there is like
some secret
thing that's going around in the
industry that i don't know about
why does it matter that i have light
mode
someone explained that to me in the chat
i need to know but anyway
you're letting me
getting all the way over
uh
we're completely away from the actual
objective of this show we're going to
talk about
games of 20
21.
actually i i wish there was like a way
is there like a
a way to find out games that released
just in 2021
does that exist
games that released in
2021
so there was a a video game thing
yeah i i enjoy uh i play i play these
games man if there's anything that
people in this chat can't say
i do play games like i i i play games
pretty consistently throughout the year
i'm not like as big into as like weapon
whale in them where they like go over
all the games they beat i know i've beat
a bunch of games this year but i never
really like go into it to find out
exactly how many i beat if that makes
sense to you guys
alright so let me
oh so i have a
it seems
that i have a show and tell
a show and tell
hold up wait a minute
oh
so i i don't think we can do that
because
i do think that that has been broke
because of
i have windows 11 now
i'll have to look at that later i don't
know
i hope they fix that like i mean windows
11 is pretty relatively soon so but i'm
pretty sure we can still use display
capture
yeah we can still use display capture
we can still use it
all right so let me
let me go back to this
we're gonna go over
the games of 2021
and for some reason
my camera isn't appearing
because that's just my luck
oh let's
there we go i don't know why that was
going on but all right so let me
lower this a little bit
because we got we got to talk about this
man we got gotta talk about there we go
let's put me up there
boom all right so here we go
there we go all right so
let's talk about let's close this ad i
don't know why this ads up there
well gaming forum i'm sure you're trying
to get paid
all right so january
we had cobra kai
iron conflict
mxgp i don't even know what that is
let's click that real quick
oh it's a biking game no wonder i didn't
know what that is
hitman 3. this is the first game i think
of the year that really took effect and
people really saw
the potential we had this year i i think
this is the first game
then you know we had let's just let's
talk over all the games because i do
have other stuff i want to talk about
but you know let's ride four what the
hell is that
it's a bike game see this is why i don't
be knowing this stuff man
yeah i use the timer too thanos i use
the timer to
thank you
[Music]
for uh i say i didn't even i don't feel
the need of bringing it up
because
i don't owe you guys an explanation of
why i
have the light mode but there it is that
that rose or thanos
however you want me to pronounce your
name
that's what really happens here is i use
the
i use the the time remote to where like
during the day it's
it's light during the night it's dark
maybe it should be flipped i don't know
if you can flip it or not but
all right so
you know we're looking through here i
would say madden's definitely a key
point of the year i don't like madden
but i know a lot of people like men
what's stronghold war lords looks like a
pc over the top
game
i don't think i'll be playing that too
much
put uh
ah that hurt put a um
i'm completely spacing david all right
put put put some logos in the chat for
any of the members here man put some
logos in that chat and uh show david
hart right uh you know he upgraded his
membership to silver appreciate that man
appreciate that
so we got control
this is a re-release though uh remember
this game got destroyed when this came
out
this game got obliterated when it came
out because a lot of people didn't like
what was going on here
oh no he's just joking like flame just
likes to to cloud on my my my
my day mode my light mode i don't think
he he's he's not mean anything by like
malice or anything by that so you know
cool down on flame flame is cool we
don't need to really go too much n m all
right so let's go over a little bit all
right so we got
control if you guys remember control
got roasted when it came out when it got
re-released because they tried to do
that new thing which it completely blew
up in their face
if i remember that correctly destruction
all-stars one of the first playstation
games to come out
this year and it flopped like it was so
bad that it went from
65 that's a 70 or 60 dollar game to like
a 20 or 30 dollar game imagine what it's
like to sit there
and buy that game for 60 dollars or them
try to sell you that game for 60 dollars
and then a couple weeks later they lower
the price drastically to 20. i think it
might have been 20. i don't remember if
it was 20 or 30. if you guys remember in
the chat definitely put that in the chat
i don't
personally remember what it was but you
know that's besides the point
let me refresh this
all right so let's let's continue let's
continue on
uh the noah two neo or noah and think
it's noah noah two remastered the
complete edition
uh this is where i was really hoping
that this game came out for play uh for
xbox it does look like this is another
one of those games that xbox just
doesn't get um you know it it went to
pc2 so i think
you know that really shows where sony
was starting to be really friendly with
pc on anything really because you know
they paid for this exclusive exclusive
so they i could see them letting their
stuff go
because they're getting the money from
that but letting this go to pc
to me
it shows
okay let's talk a little bit
i personally feel like it shows more
about a game that's going to go to pc
that they don't own because they bought
the timed exclusivity for that game they
don't really get anything if that game
goes to pc so them letting it be in the
contract to go to pc
shows that
my uh that sony is just like really
wanting to work on that pc stuff
if that makes sense to you guys
i hope it makes sense
uh
team ninja square unix and atlas are all
in bed with sony i don't know if that's
true i just think that sony's been very
vocal
about
working with them
so you know they they've been
they've been handing out bags to these
companies for years
i think microsoft just they need to be
very
big on oh on offering a bigger bag
i think that we can definitely there is
a world where these games can come to
xbox
but microsoft needs to be more
aggressive in getting these games on
xbox
um you know it is what it is like i'm
not going to say microsoft isn't doing
anything in that general
facility to try to get over to the
platform but i do feel like they need to
do more and the reason i feel like they
need to do more is because we just need
more of an effort on their part if that
makes sense to you guys
i i i it's mainly just on the games that
i want like the final fantasies the
personas i understand that's not
everyone's cup of tea
but i do feel like those games are
important to the ecosystem and not
having those games is an issue
but that's just me hold up give me a
second
i should probably
tweet the link
i need to do a better job at that
because like i first off i didn't even
really do anything
in terms of tweeting the leak because
like
i didn't even plan on doing this podcast
it's just like i woke up
after my nap
yeah i nap man i'm getting old i turned
i just had a birthday man i'm getting
old now
hold up give me a second
i am doing something
all right there we go
how to tweet man had to tweet now let's
go to my account
because that'd be me on the iop account
doing stuff with the attic show
and let's
retweet it on my account there we go all
right let's get back to this let's get
back to the good stuff all right so
let's let's read some of these comments
on the stuff i'm talking about microsoft
doesn't care sony is peanuts to them
but if sony's peanuts to them
why are they still losing this stuff to
sony
that's my point it's like
microsoft is too big of a colossal giant
and they got too much money to be
getting outbid by any company
and you know maybe it's it's a lot about
a relationship more than money there is
a lot
i'm 30. i'm 30 now i turn 30
a couple days ago but so there is a lot
of money in terms of
what they want because clearly at the
end of the day these companies they want
money but i do feel like we've gotten to
the point with
the money that it's not
always a hundred percent about money
like they still care about the
relationship they have and i think
that's what you're seeing here going to
is
they
they look into okay we're gonna get
money from microsoft and sony but we
have a better relationship with sony so
you know for what might take microsoft
20 million to get from uh from these
companies i'm just throwing a number out
there i don't know what these these
exclusives cost
might take sony 10 million because they
have such a good relationship with them
and they want to keep feeding that
relationship both companies do
attic microsoft was worried about google
and amazon not sony
they they are but they're not like
i i get what you're saying because their
biggest competitors with like cloud
computing and stuff is
um
google and amazon but at the same time
they're definitely
still worried about
about sony because
they got destroyed last generation let's
be real here they got destroyed last
generation so there is a
a means of them scared that you know
they might not necessarily be able to do
that next gen uh well this gin the xbox
series s and x like the fact that they
corrected the power narrative and they
corrected the uh you know the stuff that
sony went off for them it clearly shows
that they care about the clear
advantages that sony had over them
if that makes sense to you guys
if that makes sense
microsoft would actually want sony to
survive so they can put game pass on
playstation i do think they want game
pass on playstation is place game pass
going to go on playstation i don't know
i have no clue
but so you let's go over you know
so persona 5 strikers i remember that i
was a really big fan of the persona 5
strikers i don't really
like that dynasty warrior stuff anymore
i did in my uh you know a few years ago
i was really enjoying it
i'm young
yeah
that's what i keep telling myself i
don't feel young man i i feel
and a lot of that has to do with me i
need i need to take better care of
myself man
i need to take better care of myself i
need to really
focus this year
on just being a better me by the end of
the year it's like i said um on twitter
i'm going to stop
really entertaining the console war
stuff entirely i pulled back on a lot of
that last year
uh well this year and last year i pulled
a lot back on in terms of
how i interact with the console war
stuff but i do feel like
i need to improve more on that i need to
make sure that i don't give these people
the time of the day
to be on my timeline
so i'm gonna work on that next year i'm
gonna work on that i feel like it will
help me mentally uh you know i feel like
getting these wisdom tooth cut out will
help me mentally too
uh because it so a lot of the times when
i'd be doing the podcast i'd be in pain
i just don't really be saying anything
but it's just like it'd be a constant
throbbing in my like my right or left
wisdom tooth
but it's never gotten to the point where
i can't talk here recently it's got to
the point where i can't talk
do you think hellblade 2 is a direct
competitor to god of war no i don't
think kell blade will be able to compete
with god of war i think rice son of rome
if they made a sequel and they built
onto that franchise could have competed
with god of war but i don't think that
could have competed with god war
i think they need something else i don't
know i haven't played hellblade 2. i
never play hellblade
but
i'm not
there's issues i have with people
talking in my ear the way they do in
hellblade so i don't know if my mindset
could play that whole game i keep trying
to play but it just like puts shivers
down my spine
like it really does it'd be messing with
me mentally
microsoft worried about amazon because
amazon has deep pockets too they do but
as we've seen amazon is doing the the
luna thing and google
was doing the stadium thing i think it
was gold no it might not have been
google i don't know someone did stadia i
can't remember i'm pretty sure it was
google but i don't know if it was google
look how well that worked sometimes
having money isn't going to work for
anything if you haven't built the
infrastructure you don't want to spend
the time building the infrastructure
it's pointless to do
anything in the gaming industry you got
to build the infrastructure you got to
build the the exclusives to get people
on the platform you can't just come in
here and throw money around we've seen
multiple times that that does not work
in the gaming industry
all sony needs to do is make a
compatible
web browser for ps5 that will allow game
pass to run on its game
on uh
i disagree and i
i don't completely disagree with you on
that but i don't think that i don't
think sony wants game pass on their
platform
i like that sony's putting stuff on pc
they they definitely need to because at
the end of the day it hurts no one to
put stuff on pc no one at all
probably just hurts you not to put stuff
on pc
all right so
bravery default to i've been playing it
here recently
and it's a fun game i do think that
there's certain things that i would have
liked differently
but there's not anything that would make
me like want to turn the game off it's
actually a really fun experience
all right so
there's yakuza like a dragon i don't
know what that's here maybe that's
because it's on ps5 because that i'm
pretty sure that came out on xbox last
year
yeah ps5 yakuza like a dragon that's
another thing that's like weird that
happened this year is
yakuza like a dragon came on xbox first
for next gen for the well current gen at
this time but that at that time it was
next gen so it's kind of weird that sega
has that kind of relationship with
microsoft that they're willing to put
you know a game such as yakuza like a
dragon that they were betting a lot on
they were changing the gameplay it was a
huge move and they put that exclusively
on the xbox ecosystem uh i think you
could get it in japan
for the ps4
i don't know i can't remember but i do
know
a lot of the scenarios i hate the
presentation of bravery default too
yeah i don't like the muppet style stuff
either i felt like
you know make cutscenes like
i i if anything do it like tactics did
if like i don't like the muppets thing
they i would have preferred them like to
make like a tactic scenario over
anything
but
it's not been enough to make me not want
to play the game but
the presentation definitely should have
been changed i completely 100 agree with
you there
flame
y'all cause i like dragon was amazing it
was
i love that game
i actually think that game is on par
with like persona
i i think persona is better but i do
think that that game could go there one
day i do think it could go there one day
not right now
but one day it could be there
all right yakuza like a dragon i like
octopath graphics soda upgraded retro or
jrpg i actually beat
octopad traveler and i beat the hidden
boss too well not the hidden boss the
real end boss of the game i beat him and
he was a beast man it took me a little
it took me a long time to beat that dude
it took me a long time to beat that dude
i think i have like 80 hours in octopath
traveler hold up i think i have it
downloaded
we'll come back to this man we'll come
back to
hold that thought
hold it
we're gonna
we're gonna check out some octopath
traveler real quick
i think it's at the bottom because it's
like a relatively
small game
yeah octopod traveler here it is
uh we got a five dollar super chat from
g-man addict
love the content but this is no longer
about exclu about consoles microsoft
goes 2 billion subs with the market
share it's a whole new ball game
i agree
i do agree but i do think that they do
want
that console market like i don't think
that's something that they're a hundred
percent
down on like that's uh something that
they're going to be looking at
completely but i do think that is some
statistics that they have
a mindset towards if that makes sense to
you guys
like i don't think it's one of those
things where
that's their priority i do think that
that is one of those things where it's
like
it's something that they're looking at
but it's not something that is the only
thing
if that makes sense to you guys
[Music]
all right
oh no this boss is a beast man
i can't even remember this game too much
anymore to be honest with you guys
so this this i won't be playing this
game long i don't think i can go in here
either i like to have like beat a boss
like one of these bosses but i i i it
won't let me back in there
but like i got all the stuff for it man
i really like this game
i can't wait for that new game they're
making
i i don't know what what it's called but
i can't wait for that game
um
i still haven't beat the final ball it's
too hard for me
octopus has a good difficulty i think
after i beat halo i'm going back to
yakuza series then x i like the
turn-based yakuza and i think that's
what i'm going to stick with
uh the the other stuff i'm not saying
they're bad they're just not for me like
i don't know why i really like the way
that they approached turn base in this
game
it's it's really solid
yeah see this is my team man
it's a good game
yeah triangle strategy i'm going to be
playing that for sure
well i even went through the game
and got all
of the
the uh the battle tested stuff like for
those who don't know this battle test
stuff's like the best stuff in the game
and i even went through the game and got
that
like this is a great game
and this is still not on playstation if
i remember correctly it's kind of weird
that uh it never got put on playstation
and hopefully they'll get it soon
because this is
such a good game it deserves to go on
playstation
it's a long game man it took me
16 eight hours to beat
68 hours it took me to beat
yeah i i i generally if it's a turn
based game you have a lot better chance
of getting me to play it like uh
phoenix point final fantasy
except for this i'm not really too big
on that but we'll go back to what g-man
was talking about because i like talking
to the chat you know we get a good
little conversation going
we'll go back eventually
let me switch scenes
give me one second let me get a drink
real quick
ah
got a little power like we're not
sponsored by
by propel like at all but this is what
i've been drinking here lately
cognito set me up with these man he uh
he he put me on to them that they they
good i like them
let's go back to the chilling
position man let's go back to it
games like this and persona should be on
everything i agree but the thing is is
until microsoft's gonna be more
aggressive in
getting that stuff i don't see it being
like that if that makes sense to you
guys
like microsoft has to take the
initiative to make sure this stuff is on
their platform
[Laughter]
uh hold up
what's going on here ayo if it is meteor
meet orca
man they bout to go at you in that chat
man
look there is a lot of issues with halo
infinite but it's not anything drastic
enough to make me want to drop the game
it was still very fun game to play
you know and i enjoyed it i really did i
enjoyed it quite a bit i can't say i did
i enjoyed uh
that game
i've been thinking about doing a play
through a fable
at a
fable here i thought you were a
non-alcoholic this is not alcohol
like
what makes you does that look like
alcohol to you
how does that look like alcohol
that is a propel my dude
i think it's saying it backwards i think
i have to change the settings for that i
don't know
intermission
i do need to get this changed um i don't
like the term intermission
i think it needs to be fixed oh no it it
it is i'm looking at the playback it is
a right side up all right so that's cool
it's just backwards of mine it's not
backwards on here guys is it
i like confident more than doom doom's a
good game i don't know if i would say
infinite's better than doom i feel like
maybe doom
is a better overall game than infinite i
don't know because the multiplayer on
infinite is good and there's not really
a multiplayer of that caliber on any of
the doom franchise so i think that might
balance the force a little bit if that
makes sense to you guys
halo could be finished in 20 hours and
has no replay value
i mean you're not wrong
but at the end of the day does that
really matter
you know like
to me
what matters is if you enjoyed the game
addict is on the rand diet actually
i've been on
the propel longer than ran
ran buys them by like the cases and i
need to start doing that
addict you're going to unfollow xbox
university he attacked digital foundry
made fun of when they channel got hacked
just because they criticized halo
look
i don't agree with him attacking digital
foundry but i i'm not the
i'm not the
the twitter police
if you guys have an issue with halo and
halo dammit xbox university speak right
at it
go
talk to xbox university
because like to me
i can't i can't control that man's on on
twitter
you know he's his own person if he
doesn't want to do that then he don't
have to do that
dude plays way better come on man
uh are you talking to me because
i don't feel like i said one plays
better than the other i feel like you're
talking to someone else
ninja drunken ninja you know better to
to to stand against me
you know i ain't gonna handle that
i'ma get you
the story is awful but so is halos
uh
i don't really
i feel like
i don't know that's that's a rough one
do maternal i i don't know if that's an
amazing experience but i don't think
it's one of those things where i would
say it's better or worse if that makes
sense to you guys
and movement based co instead of cover
uh
i don't know we i don't feel like we
should talk about that like you know
let's go back to the le you know games
of 2021 let's go back to that man
because i feel like we were we we had a
moment with that man we had a moment
with that we let's go back to that
bam
so let's let's skip certain things that
we know
marvel avengers
that was probably one of the biggest
upsets i've seen in the gaming industry
in quite a bit i'm not gonna lie to you
guys huge upset in the gaming industry
this is when kingdom hearts franchise
finally went to pc
it's interesting
you know it took so long for this game
to come out for xbox and i still never
beat them on xbox because i beat them so
many times on multiple different
platforms that i didn't want to go back
and play them again
we got april outriders i remember this
time of the year man who remembers when
outriders came out remember when that
game passed day and date was announced
it was a pretty crazy week that week
it's a pretty crazy week
all right
so
nothing really
here stands out to me besides that
outriders
ash walkers i don't even know what that
is
super meat boy forever i'm sure a lot of
people would like that and then mlb the
show microsoft snatched that too
you know that that was a big thing man i
remember how crazy it was
on
twitter when that happened
oh you could have shown more skin nah
i'm good man i'm not gonna show no skin
ain't nobody want to see a dude like
that man there's other places you can go
to see that man you don't need to see it
here
don't need to come to the podcast
and see it here man you got plenty of
places you can go see that
i see you know let's back to mlb it will
be the show
what made this so big
is because mlb the show
was a playstation exclusive game in the
first iteration of it to come to xbox
microsoft was able to negotiate with mlg
and get it on game pass day and date now
it's debatable if sony knew this was
going down people like to say they did
and i think that's that's that that's
bull there's no way
sure they might not have liked it but
sony definitely knew it was going to
happen
uh immortals the phoenix rise and that
was a good game i really enjoyed that i
didn't play the dlc but that was a good
game in general
pokemon snap i remember i was kind of
hyped for pokemon snap and i never
bought it
because i love the old pokemon games and
i never bought that genship impact i
assumed that was the ps5 update
ps5 update
uh
return on for the ps5 april the 30th
this is the first big game
and geez they kind of dropped the ball
man we could all agree that that when it
come to return
playstation dropped the ball on return
uh not necessarily on what the game was
about and the it was the quality of the
game when it launched felt like could
have been a lot better and i think they
need to work on making sure games
that operate like fraternal come out
functioning good
uh but you know i think we're at the end
like the core of fraternal is good it's
just they need to make sure
that they never let that happen again
so apparently resident evil village
comes on here
all right so yeah resident evil village
may the seventh that was a good game
i didn't play it but it was a good game
i played probably an hour and a half of
it i've been told it's really really
short so i probably could have beat that
game
but i didn't finish it but i was told
that you know it was a good game
uh
destiny 2 season of splicer
i didn't really play too much destiny
this year i'm gonna be wrong
i'm gonna be honest with you guys i kind
of like dropped destiny a little bit uh
up until
february because that's when the witch
queen comes out
mass effect the legendary edition i
reviewed that game
i
was sleeping on mass effect and i'm glad
that i actually got
to come around and play it it was um it
was a good game i really enjoyed mass
effect and i feel like
though that might be the best trilogy
ever made i'm gonna just be real with
you guys i feel like mass effect really
might be the best trilogy ever made and
there's multiple reasons that i feel
that way i feel that way because
they did such a good job
in doing game to game that you never
really see anymore ever
so i'm really happy about that
uh knockout city i played that a little
bit not too much
uh me and uh one of my friends uh cat
daddy we played that and it was a it was
an okay game but
i don't know if it was one of those
things that you would keep playing if
that makes sense like
i feel like there was a lot of gameplay
issues with that game
and
it's not bad and i'm sure it's still fun
but they need to they definitely need to
fix things up
final fantasy 14 on ps5 i'm assuming
that's the next gen update
the next gen update june e3 time
i don't really see a whole lot here
elder scrolls uh
went on
so the gates of oblivion so that was
integration that was a good so june was
an okay month integration was good
um
that's about all i don't really see
anything else to be honest with you
scarlet nexus
i've been told it's a good game i have
it i still haven't played it but i have
been told that uh it's a good game
the legend of zelda
yeah right here the july the 16th
i streamed that game for an hour
what's funny is me and king used to
argue about
skyward sword and
you know
i was one of those people that i didn't
like the motion gimmicks
but when i played it in july and they
fixed some of the motion gamepl
thought process into the legend of zelda
skyward sword
i think that
i know people are going to really get
onto me for this
i think that legend of zelda skyward
sword is a better game the breath of the
wild
and i say that strictly in terms of what
a zelda game represents to me and i felt
like breath of the wild didn't represent
as a zelda game it's a really good open
world
action game but i don't feel like zelda
breath of the wild was a good zelda game
and it felt like skyrim sword had the
temples had the the the story it felt
like a zelda game
zelda breath of the wild doesn't feel
like a zelda game to me
and i i know that
some people disagree with that but
that's just my opinion on it i do i i do
give more respect to skyward sword uh
you know i i completely bit the need to
to king i told him i was wrong about
skyrocket sword you know it's not the
greatest game in the world and
especially zelda wise it's definitely
not one of the best zelda y's but i do
think that it is a good zelda game it's
just that they would have completely
fixed the
the motion sensing in the game
that's probably when they would have got
that
how can they get on to you for that next
you know how these people are if i say
anything negative about breath of the
wild they on me man they on me
uh that seems to be about all here
this final fantasy
pixel uh remaster series why didn't that
come on consoles
why is that only on steam
ios and android
i hate when they use that stuff if you
can put it on the platform why don't you
put it on the platform sony is big
enough
uh or not sony
square enix is a big enough publisher
they could easily put it on there
all right
the ascent
there's an individual earlier i can't
remember which one of you i think it was
uh i think he's still in the i think i
saw him
say something let me look
all right i've
i don't know if he's still in here but
he apparently i
said that the scent was good i don't
think i remember saying that i think if
you guys remember correctly i said that
i didn't like
the scent because there was a lot of
issues in that game
uh it's not saying that they sent a bad
game because i don't think it's a bad
game i just think that the
technical issues i was dealing with when
that game started was crazy bad we got a
two dollar street trap from flames
scarlet nexus has good gameplay story
sucks
uh when i played the demo i agree with
you i didn't play of the story the
actual retail game much if any i don't
know if i even booted that game up but
uh i actually enjoy what i played on the
demo i need to go back to that there's a
couple games i need to go back to i
never played village this year and i
never played scarlet nexus i need to
finish psychonauts because i didn't beat
that either
um
[Music]
i don't
need any of that stuff right now
right now i'm fine i don't need like
orjo anything i do have um
a bag
hold up
let me show you how real
my toothache has been
like how real
it's been for me man let me show you how
real
i
have a shoe
i have a baggie full of stuff for
toothache stuff depending on what
exactly is wrong with uh how the kind of
toothache pain i'm having i have
literally a bag full
of like you know ibuprofen or gel
um
i do have my antibiotics that the doctor
gave me a couple weeks ago
uh for that i've been taking
they're about gone though because that's
the reason my tooth feels better but um
yeah it it was that real man it was that
real i
i was in that much pain that i would
literally have a bag in my car
dedicated to fixing the tooth pain
yeah it was definitely buggy
yeah it was gaming xtc yeah he's the one
that individual he probably just
misheard that podcast
because uh you know when people are
talking like they are in podcast
sometimes it gets a little
confusing uh but i definitely understand
if you got that confused but that
definitely wasn't me
uh
12 minutes was a letdown a little bit to
me
did you hear that call got a job at
oculus or whatever
call i knew about that before you guys
knew about that you guys really thought
you found that out first
um
it's wisdom tooth i got impacted wisdom
tooth i got two of them
uh this thursday i'm actually having
them all removed
all of my wisdom tooth
uh i only need two of them removed but
the doctor said
let's just get them all up out of there
let's just get them all up out of there
so that's what we doing
i don't really see anything else in this
month in august
besides what we brought over i remember
this where is it
the boyfriend dungeon i remember that
started some stuff
september
the artful escape that was a game of the
year contender
death loop that was a great game i
actually enjoyed that i know a lot of
people don't like that flu but i
actually like that flute
i think you guys just need to stop
hating
you know
it's been an okay here i don't think
the year has been so bad
that
we can't you know the year's been a a
decent year i will say that the year has
been one of those years where
i would enjoy playing
like this year it's just i feel like
there hasn't been that one big game that
you're like this is it this is game of
the year
there's no
no
doubt in my mind that this is where it
all starts and i feel like in terms of
that that's where uh that's what we was
missing we was missing like the witcher
3
uh you know
a fallout game because i know a lot of
fallouts can nominate for game of the
year now halo infinite i think is the
closest thing
but you better all right
look man cog
is a beast at what he does i can't touch
that quality car just puts a lot of time
and stuff and like i lose so much of
attention span i can't keep my mindset
that long it's crazy the amount of work
that cog does
to set up some of these iops you guys
have no idea
how long cog be taking to make some of
these uh
intros and stuff on iop he does a lot of
research a lot of commitment man a lot
of commitment he uh he doesn't get
enough nearly enough praise that he
should
listen bro uh
man you guys are really going at that
liberal mind dude like let him breathe
if he if you don't agree with everything
he's saying that's fine
it's not a big deal but you guys
constantly attacking him for his opinion
that's gonna put less
you know
validation upon what you're saying
it's not that serious guys it's not that
serious
guys don't have to go that far
alright so
let's talk about halo infinite
let's talk about it
halo infinite i feel like it's a really
solid experience
i really enjoy it uh single player you
guys saw i reviewed it i reviewed that
and the multiplayer halo infinite is
probably
i would say because i played yakuza this
year i pl i that's my game of the year
is yakuza
but
halo is the runner-up for me because it
was a very good experience i feel like
halo
343 i don't think 343 has redemmed
himself yet but i think damn this is
close
like you know
i know people don't like some of the
stuff that they've done in halo let me
switch the the screens again
there we go
i know
some people didn't enjoy some of the
stuff that they did
is it not gonna work
hello
see this is what i'll be talking about
man
why isn't my video card working
oh my god
it's not even a big deal it is a big
deal but i'm not gonna even
give it any kind of
i don't know why that's not working
that's weird
can you guys hear the halo thing in the
background
i like to have the music playing while
i'm talking
but they messing with me
uh
i don't think it's working
i think you guys can hear me but you
can't hear it
which is weird
because they they be constantly messing
this up
sometimes i'd be getting annoyed
you know
people don't realize how much
stuff that content creators deal with
on literally this was just working
like it was literally just working
i don't know why
it's not working now it was literally
just working
when
i
capture cards and apps
when we were just doing this like when
we brought this in earlier
it was working but now
now for some reason it doesn't want to
work
and i i don't know
why
we have issues like that
[Music]
and what i mean it might be windows 11
because i got windows 11 they kind of
forced it on me i don't know how it
happened i thought you couldn't get
forced on windows 11
but it seems like i'm being forced with
windows 11.
so that's unfortunate
all right so let's see if this fixes it
it's weird that
it's not working
oh let me check my settings
i think i know what it is guys
i think i know what it is
i think i got that new setting on where
you can't
like what it does is it like removes the
the volume from the from the output and
it puts it in your uh in your headset
i gotta turn that off
allow pastor
uh
no it's not
i don't know why
my
capture card's not working
it's weird but i'm not gonna keep
worrying about it it's not a big deal
it is a big deal but
i have to figure out why that's not
working later
halo infinite's in a good spot i feel
like halo infinite can actually come out
of this on top they just need to do a
couple things they are do they have done
a lot of good things
in terms of how they're playing this
game out but they do need more we need
more maps i feel like you know the
biggest thing they can do right now
is just go ahead and really just look at
older maps let me reset it see if that
fixes it just look at older maps like
i'd like guardian in here the pit
you know i think there's a lot of good
games that you could play in here and i
think that that's something that they
should really look into i want a lot of
the old maps in this so we can actually
sit down and really enjoy
you know the pit like i said you know
how much of halo 3 is in there and how
much i would love to play that game
play some of these older ones that
that's what i want i want them to
really focus on
getting us older maps i think that's
that's where i want
what do you guys want do you guys think
that you know older maps will work
i'm kind of curious
you guys think that they need older maps
i think they need older maps
yeah i probably accidentally accepted it
uh i feel like they need good maps too
like i'm not saying the maps they have
now is bad
but i do feel like
some of the older maps
is some of the best maps in in halo if
that makes sense to you guys
kind of curious to hear you guys opinion
um
give me one brief second guys
i'm so
weird why
that's not working
attic behemoth equals uh guardian remade
just saying
i can't get down on that man
um behemoth is that a map because i'm
not too familiar with the maps on here
yet
hold up
custom game
no that is not guardian come on man
you really trying to say that's guardian
this is not guardian
i hope is this what you trying to say is
guardian who said that let's find this
dude who said that
gaming xtc that's not guardian man
i don't have halo
halo
the the collectors edition downloaded i
would show you what guardian is
pits from halo 3 yes
actually
ah that's not guardian i don't know why
you would think that's guardian
guardian
is nothing like that map but anyway
let's let's go on that
they need more of that they need
i people
said that
i don't like the ranking list i don't i
don't like starting with brs i know
that's halo and i'm not saying it
shouldn't be that way but i personally
feel like if you literally
play put halo in a box and only allow
people and allow people to play with the
br you're going to get scenarios where
people are only playing with the br i
don't think that's good for the game i
think it's pointless having promoting
one gun that everyone uses when there's
so many other guns that's in the game
i feel like it hurts the game have
everyone starved ars in a pistol and
have everyone fight for everything on
the map
that's just my opinion and i know you
guys disagree and i know that's what
halo is to a lot of people and that's
fine but to me
halo is not about to be our halo's about
map control and the br defeats the
purpose of map control because only
one's ever gonna use with one gun i see
people all the time in ranked just pick
up power weapons and never use them they
don't use any other weapon on the map
and when you look at the kill feed it's
literally nothing but br brb rbr how is
that fun and i get it
it's very competitive but at the same
time what's the point in promoting map
control and fighting for objectives on a
map when the only thing people are going
to use the br
i will give you
ah
i don't know
i don't think that's a remake of that
either
um
i feel like
i don't think that's a remake man
why are you getting me off on this on
these tangents man
where is it this
i don't think that's a remake i'ma just
i'ma just call it that uh halo should
make a br i'm gonna be honest i do feel
like br is important to put in halo and
it they were showing like
like leaked
images of like a red screen going on the
map like a red circle going on the map
like sir
closing on these maps that you see in
front of me
i don't feel like that's the correct way
to make a br if you're not going to make
a br correctly don't even try to make a
br sure you can put your own little spin
on it with you know putting br's on
these maps but i don't feel like that's
the br people want people want br
naturally you go and you get the weapons
people want that kind of br they don't
want just a shrinking circle on the
existing maps of this game
that's just my opinion like
make a br correctly or don't make one at
all
like make the reach map
make you know you cut you i don't think
you should come in as spartans i think
you should come in maybe come in as
spartans but i do think you should drop
down in odsd parts i do think that's the
best thing you know
drop down an odsd ball i do think they
need to redo the
call out system in this game what's
going on bitcloud
and i think that needs to be worked on
the the call out system because i think
it's right now it's pretty bad
i feel like it's inconsistent sometimes
it like it does point out on the map
where it is
but there's no indication when you're
actually playing the game if you're in
that's that right map you only see the
notification i don't know i don't even
remember how long it comes up but to me
it's like you know i like the way apex
legends does their stuff
i don't know man
i don't feel like all uh
this map that this map right here
i don't feel like that's midship remake
reimagining like
i think that's just a unique map that
they made i don't think like it's any
certain map reimagined i feel like this
map right here
is just that map
uh it does say version 1.0 so maybe they
got some plans for
this in the future i don't know what
that's about but you know
they need more maps that's the whole
point of this
let's get some guardian in here let's
get some the pit let's get some foundry
i do feel like i will give you this
uh gamer nxt i do think
foundry from halo 3
i feel like recharge is
like kind of kind of a spiritual
successor of that
yeah i i just want halo content in there
too
you guys better get those player numbers
up if you want a br mode added
no there's already a br mode all the
ranked is is br starts
i just don't i don't like that like it's
like i said i want to play a diverse
game with diverse weapons i don't want
to play a mode where everyone just uses
one weapon and then if you look at like
community games in this community most
of everyone won't play really without br
starts because a vast majority of the
halo community can only use one weapon
and i feel like that
that's not good like they need
to
they need to
be one of those people where it's like
look like we're going to have diverse
uh a diverse set of weapons
what's the point having the sentinel if
no one's going to use it what's the
point of having a shotgun if no one's
going to use it the mongolia if no one's
going to use it if you do br ranks like
they're doing now
everyone's going to use a br no one's
going to use anything else very rarely
do you ever see anything that's not br
and sure that's a lot about to me is i'm
not as good with the br as other people
are and that definitely has something to
do with it but at the same time
i like halo to play with other weapons
and i feel like
a game mode with everyone starts with br
doesn't reward people for trying new
things
that's why i feel like
br should be a thing that's on the map
that you have to fight for
i don't mind the pistol
and the pistol can even get a little bit
more of a buff
i don't mind the pistol but i do mind
the br because i feel like
there's certain people and i know that
you know what i'm about to say is going
to sound crazy there's certain people
you can't mess with for br and then to a
lot of the high ranked players of halo
a br is just as deadly as is a rocket
launcher maybe not
like obviously an aoe of a rocket launch
is going to kill more people than br but
some people can get more kills with a br
than they can a rocket launcher
well guess what we need to go away from
that like to me
halo is about map control and br
contradicts map control
no one is fighting for anything
when everyone has the weapon they want
now if you had to fight for the br at a
certain place at the map you would see
fights going on to fight for that br but
you don't see that the only thing you
see is people fighting for
for like equipment for the overshield
for for camo and that's fine let's let's
keep that i want people to have to fight
over that i'm just saying can we fight
for something else besides equipment
please
that's just my opinion on the matter
and that's fine but to me it's like i
said
halo is about controlling the map
and deciding what you're willing to
sacrifice for what you're willing to
gain are you going to fight for the
shotgun or you're going to fight for the
energy weapon are you going to lock down
those parts of the map so the other team
can't get it
that's what
that is to me
and to me
they don't do it correctly to me br
starts encourages people to only go
around and fight and sh and shoot people
it doesn't encourage a map control
i don't know man i've seen people do
some crazy [ __ ] with that br
i mean you could say i'm cr i'm crazy
it's cool like i'll still play br but br
starts but i don't like it i really
don't
like i i just feel like it doesn't at
the roots of halo it contradicts what
halo's about
i love the sound man i wish you guys
could hear the
halo but
for some reason it's it's it's not
working i don't know why i tried
multiple times to get
the video card to show the audio but i
probably have to like reset obs or
something i think when i when i put on
octopath traveler
it was there
but for some reason it's not there
anymore
maybe i messed up i don't know
had to let the cat about came back and
thought br was battle royale yeah they
they
for halo same br because people are so
familiar with how popular the br is it's
definitely something that gets
like miscommunication a lot because
people know what the br is people do not
know what battle royale
comparator br is so people think that
they're the same thing maybe for halo we
should just start calling
battle royale like an actual like the
actual name and i said br
oh okay okay i get what you're saying
now i thought you were talking about br
yeah
put battle royale
or br like don't put br because i'll get
it confused i'll get it confused like i
said i think i think
dr disrespect was right halo does need a
battle royale
i don't know when uh you know not at
launch but i do think you need to drop a
battle royale a well done battle royale
six months to a year after halo infant
comes out to breathe more life into the
brand to bring more life into the game i
know a lot of people don't like some of
these big streamers but at the end of
the day guess what these big streamers
they know what they're talking about in
terms of what's hot what people are
watching what the trend are what people
are going to gravitate towards they're
not wrong in that sure sometimes they're
a little bit too much in how they they
try to get their stuff and i will say to
a point some of their stuff is biased
they want stuff to have br because
that's what their brand is so you know
they want to have stuff to stream to
people
no i i haven't played destiny a lot i
need to get back on destiny
i do i do it's not that i hate destiny i
just feel like right now
destiny isn't
where it needs to be
um it's gotten better with this like
30th anniversary thing but i do think it
needs to improve some more
the original halo games aged badly this
is coming from someone playing the
series before uh since 04. i agree with
you some of them did i don't think that
age badly to the point that they can't
be played but you can see the age in the
game
halo can survive with that one but a
good br could make it so popular i agree
with you halo definitely could survive
without a
battle royale
but i do feel like they need it they
need it because
their
sooner or later
the gameplay and halo is going to get
still
and that's not from people like me
playing it's from the casual people that
play fortnite that play warzone that's
why you need to get them in there uh you
know
and sure you might split your fan base a
little bit i like imagine like
i feel like halo is a great game to do
battle royale that's why i don't feel
like i don't understand why people get
upset when people say to put one in halo
i don't think
that i think it's a good game to have
battle royale
drop certain guns down
you know i think it should be more map
controlled battle royale than anything
not necessarily gun control but gun
control is important but i think it
should be a lot more map control like
maybe have certain retraction bridges
like bridges that you could put up i
think you can go that direction with
a battle royale
obviously have other ways of getting to
every objective but have shortcuts that
you can if you fight for that objective
on the map you can like raise bridges
and stuff i think that's a good way of
doing battle royale because it still
is the core of halo
but it's not so far-fetched that you
wouldn't expect it to be different from
a battle royale
see but you can't have that kind of
mindset life supremacy like you have to
try to make sure that you still
incorporate things that's popular right
now and i think halo can do that it'd be
different if i felt like halo couldn't
achieve a battle royale make sense and
be true to the brand but i do think it
can
valor it's far from trash you probably
get embodied look never played valor uh
i kind of want to try it one day i kind
of want to try it
probably give you guys uh we're about to
talk about the state of gaming here soon
because i think it's looking good it's
looking real good
so let
so
in conclusion to halo infinite i think
the campaign needs to evolve throughout
years i don't want them doing what
destiny does where
they do like a season pass i want them
just to focus on maybe two big
expansions a year one at the beginning
one at the end and just have that tell
the story of halo infinite and then just
warrior uh you know focus on the
multiplayer
doing that i don't want them to like
drip feed us content i want two big
content two big content drops a year and
i feel like that would be the best case
for halo infinite i don't know if
they're going to do that we'll have to
see but that's the way i would want them
to handle how you infinite
yeah
uh perfect shot i get that but i feel
like
they could easily do this they just have
to you got to put time behind it you got
to get people like you know as much as
you guys don't like it doctor disrespect
you know gotta get some developers that
make battle royale gotta get some people
that play religiously and you gotta find
a good way to incorporate into halo
infinite universe
i don't think valor is on steam i think
you have i think they have their own
website you have to download it on
i don't know though i don't play valor
but valor is definitely a big game
people that keep clowning valor in the
chat
uh
i don't think you really like know
what you're talking about in terms of
valor like it's a really big game
but that's just me that's just me
battle roy wouldn't be a trend for iowa
when it pretty much has a story and
modes like big team battle which already
has that's cool then then what they need
to do instead of making a big team
instead of making a battle royale they
need to evolve a big team battle kind of
like what they did with war zone but do
it where it's not so microtransactional
and evolve it properly
kind of make it like more of like a
battlefield scenario where it's like 32
guardians on 32 big maps you have you
know a big
giant uh
big giant
planes
uh pelicans you know you got scorpions
like hold up to three
make it more something like that but i
do feel like some of the core things
when it comes to more people
look i'm not going to tell you big team
battle isn't as bad because i don't
think it is big team battle is good
but i do think that they need something
else besides just big team battle
but as far as the story that's why i
said you know every
every six months drop uh a
sizeable content and story of
five five to ten missions welsh told
missions
some new lore
and i think we'll be fine with that
250 million pcs and xbox games with 60k
peak
the thing about pc gamers though is pc
gamers are all
fickle they're everywhere they're
playing
valor they playing fortnite they're
playing all the little games that's in
there they're playing mods on stuff
so you know there is a lot of
scenarios that goes into why
the 250 million on pc just because
people have just because pc has the
potential to get 250 million people
doesn't mean that's how many people are
playing
how many people in this chat have a
steam account that never use it how many
people in this chat has made multiple
steam accounts because they lost access
to their first one they still count that
that's still a user on steam
that's what i would like i would like
for them to do kind of like call of duty
blackout does where
the maps of halo is on the battle royale
map like guardian the pit
haven from halo 4 and maybe even have
multiple of them switch stuff up like i
think that would be cool i don't know
how much work that would take but it
would be cool
br meta ruins the gun play
that's why i'm saying make it make sense
to halo it's not fortnite you ain't
building eiffel towers make it make
sense to halo
so let's
besides halo you guys you guys know how
i feel about halo an amazing game go
download go down there right now
let's talk about
the future of gaming the state of gaming
let's talk about that
i feel like we're in a really good spot
right now guys i feel like xbox
playstation and nintendo a little bit
less on
on on playstation because i do feel like
they got a little
stuff that they got to work on for me
personally uh because you know over here
on xbox i'm really enjoying the future
of xbox maybe it's not necessarily that
i feel like playstation doesn't have
more to offer maybe it's because for
right now they're offering the same type
of game and i feel like xbox is being
very diverse in how they offer their
games you got
services such as game pass where you can
get access to a lot of different stuff
you can have it pretty much
gamer uh there's games for anyone game
for any genre and for games that gamers
that really enjoy multiple different
genres
you can really get your bang for your
buck because they're offering something
for everyone and i think that's what we
really need to you know congratulate
microsoft for is they're offering that
kind of perspective to everyone and i
don't think that people really give
microsoft the kudos for that sure some
of them are on pc sure we get gears
tactics on pc before xbox sure we get
age of empires on pc and it's probably
not coming to xbox and if it does it'll
be in like six months to a year but it's
still accessible if you want to play it
you could still get a pc if you want to
play agent vampires you could still get
a pc if you want to play halo infinite i
do feel like microsoft needs to be
better on offering
exclusive stuff to both platforms if
you're going to give age of empires
exclusively on pc make sure there's
something to balance it on p on xbox
because i do feel like that is an issue
you know because you're clearly favoring
one brand over the other gears tactics
and that's another thing if a game can
work on console i can understand age of
empires if you can't get that working on
console
that's fine
every now and then games to go on a pc
only i can understand that because
certain things you need the keyboard and
mouse for but gears tactics there's no
reason why that game couldn't have came
on xbox they pushed that on pc because
they wanted to appeal to that pc crowd
first and i get that but at the same
time you need to put stuff on xbox 2. if
you can make a game work on xbox and you
put it on pc exclusively only that's
[ __ ] and they need to make sure that
they don't do that
that's my only issue what they do with
this pc stuff it's like look
gears tactics is an amazing game no
reason why the xbox cried had to wait
for that no reason microsoft should be
ashamed of how they handled that
situation
and if age of empires 4 comes to console
that's cool and that shows again we're
let's talk about um
flight simulator sure might be a little
bit different because i think that's
only on xbox series s snx but
maybe you should have delayed the x the
pc version to make sure they come out at
the same time
maybe that maybe delay it from last year
to the launch con the launch date of the
console
uh that that's my personal
uh representation of that and i know
that's i know nothing about running a
multi-trillion dollar company or running
a gaming division such as xbox but this
is me looking from the outside looking
in as an xbox content creator and as an
xbox gamer and as a gamer in general i i
see
the fact that you know there are certain
things that i don't like it's literally
called pc game pass it wasn't called pc
game pass for a while but even if it is
called pc game pass it still has an xbox
studio making that game
there is no xbox exclusive game so part
of me feels like if you're going to to
do this you know all everyone plays
scenario what they're always saying you
can't have it one way and not the other
if you're going to save these type of
terms it should be on both ends of the
spectrum not just pc not just xbox it
should be both
that was a rant that i did not intend on
doing
i don't i don't believe in that um
it says i said chill addict rts game
should i only have pc in mind first i
don't believe in that if a game can
function on console it should be on
console
and dylan a saying xbox players are
second-class citizens i don't blame for
people for feeling that way because when
we're paying xbox live gold
and pc sure they're not getting gold
games with gold but let's be real here
games with gold isn't worth paying for
anyway and we're having to pay for that
on top of not getting certain exclusives
first or at least at the same time that
pc does how is people supposed to feel
are you supposed we supposed to just let
that slide no
that is not right and they need to make
sure that they do better on that going
forward
look man dylan hey you being too much in
that chat man i'm gonna be real with you
you gotta calm down a little bit gotta
calm down a little bit being too much in
that chat
but
regardless if they have an issue with
some of
the
what's what i'm looking for
some of the messaging some of the stuff
that they do
i honestly will say
xbox has a very good future
and i think that people need to see that
i can't i gotta have this on i don't
know why
i just gotta have it on
i think that xbox has a good future they
do they
you know let me bring up a page
let me
let me bring up a page guys
did i delete that yeah i did
no
no matter
um
uh
i don't know if i want to talk about
that
we got a two dollar super chat from dv
uh opinions on ubisoft losing a ton of
employees
i've said this multiple times over and
over again and part of the reason i
don't even want to talk about it but i'm
going to is because i'm tired of
repeating myself
the
these slimy people in these companies
men and women because women be doing it
too just not as much as men
look if they doing these and they making
people feel uncomfortable i don't know
if this is ubisoft i'm talking mainly
about the blizzard thing i'm assuming
ubisoft is a relatively around the same
thing people getting passed up for
promotions people getting you know uh
having toxic environments we need to get
these men up out of here these men these
women need to get all these management
up out here there should be no pascal no
collect 200 get them up out of here
that's only thing i have to say about
that
like and people need
need to be more vocal about that like
you know there are certain scenarios
where you know
just saying that we're not for
toxic environments is not enough call
companies out don't just say we're
because that's the part that annoys me
people will say oh
we're not for
uh you know toxic environments we're for
this more for that but they won't call
the actual company that's being attacked
like blizzard like ubisoft like it's
like look like if you have an issue of
how things are being ran don't try to be
general statements
call that company out directly
but that's just me you know i get it
there's a lot of stuff that goes on
behind closed doors and i think people
need to realize that
everything is not
a black and white area there's a lot of
gray in the world
sears actually quote to a pretty
powerful pc i agree at it
no reason exclusive for peace that's
what all i'm saying man if if if the
biggest reason they can't do it is
because a pc
is because a keyboard a mouse i can get
down on that logic i think it still
sucks but i can get down on that logic
all right so
hey i agree with you man i agree with
you they're going to do whatever they
can
to get your money
they go do whatever they can
all right
all right so let's go over
here this is a very good bright future i
have to be honest with you guys like the
fact that
this is xbox's game studio
this is exciting
to be an xbox gamer to be a gamer in
general because even if you're on pc you
have access to these games
sure some of these online games you
might run into some cheaters you can run
the cheaters on pc and console but i
feel like it's more
dominant on pc it's more open on pc
people openly say they cheat on twitter
on pc you don't see that a whole lot of
games on on consoles
so 343 obviously we know who they just
made halo infinite great game scored
high
people loved it world's edge made like
an like a great game too i think it was
like an 83 84 on metacritic solid solid
review
score
people loved it the the age of empire
community loved that game i i have
people in in discords right now playing
that for the most part the coalition we
ain't seen them in a couple years and
we're going to see them probably in the
next couple years uh that clear i think
it was rumored that they they're going
to work on something else before they
work on another company on another game
so we won't see a gears for them next so
that's interesting that you know we
might actually see
them work on something else compulsion
games keep in mind this is the only
company we don't know anything about
so i'm kind of curious
on why microsoft has been so hush-hush
with this particular company can people
put in the chat what you guys think it's
gonna be we have the project midnight
link that jazz gordon did which was
pretty good league but we gotta be
realistic here we still don't know
nothing about that game double fine they
make quality platformers i'm still with
my hashtag mcbanjo kazooie double fine
take some people from rare
and take some people from double fine
hire some contractors if you need to
and get that done we need a badge of
kazooie and i'm tired of people acting
like i don't deserve my banjo-kazooie
i don't care about perfect dirt but i
don't go on a rant saying we don't need
perfect art because i can understand
people like perfect dart so understand i
want my badger kazooie get off my back
people not
specifically talking about any
particular person in the chat but you
guys get what i'm saying the initiative
once again i don't care about perfect
dark but i understand it is to a
demographic of people that's on game
pass people are going to enjoy that game
for instance netflix
right now
i haven't been able to cancel that
service
witcher came out this year uh this month
not too long ago
um
what's it called why season three came
out that was in october november i think
it was seven deadly sins i can't
remember if it was that exact month but
they're always releasing good movies
well relatively okay movies i feel like
they do way better on tv shows they do
movies but that's just me
when am i ever gonna cancel that service
not to mention the months that if i
would cancel it i'll forget
that's that's that's what we're talking
about on here
exile make great games games that i love
you know they just made the witcher you
guys
not the witcher wasteland you guys saw
how much i enjoy turn-based games and
they do it really well
look perfect shogun
i'ma
point out that i want my banjo kazooie
and they ain't a damn thing you can do
about it
ninja theory we saw how good hellblade 2
looked it's going to be a great game
obsidian we the outer worlds and avowed
going to be great games playground games
fable and forza horizon six whoever the
hell they make next great games
rare they're probably going to continue
making c at these until they figure out
whatever wild it's going to be
turn ten more
more
forza mortar
seven or six or eight or nine don't play
racing games i don't know what number
they're on but clearly that's going to
be something here i will say undead labs
is a is a wild card we don't know what
kind of quality undead labs is going to
be
but i got hope for them but we got to
see exactly what they do
now but there's the software
bethesda
game studios making starfield
and
elder scrolls six
people what's up uh oh j90 people that
sleep on this on this product on
on the elder scrolls six
you guys have no idea
the amount of magnitude that people love
that game you guys have no idea the
amount
of
noise that this game is going to make
the closer we get to its release sure
it's going to be a couple years we
probably won't see nothing on it for
probably two to three years and the game
probably won't come out for three to
four years but when this game starts
dropping information
it's going to be an event
star field comes out next year
that's up in the air and i'll give you
guys that we can give
our reserves where we have to see more
about star field i personally am excited
for starfield because they make games
that i enjoy
alpha dog games
one of these studios
is a mobile studio but i don't know
which one it is
i don't think it's roundhouse studios it
might be roundhouse
but i don't know it's neither alpha dog
or roundhouse i think i think it's alpha
dog i think alpha dog's the mobile
studio but zenimax online great game for
gamepad great studio for game pass
always going to pop out the elder
scrolls and the fallout 4's i don't
think they work on fallout 4 but fallout
76 but i'm sure
at some point they've helped uh helped
the
but that's the software i think the
austin studio make it
uh tango game uh game work obviously the
next game is going to be an exclusive
for playstation but after that maybe
we'll get an evil within three i know a
lot of people like evil then
it's a lot of people sleeping on
on that game
eric the beard
yeah i kind of figured out for dog was
the mobile studio they're probably the
people in the made fallout shelter
id
doom is fantastic
i don't think they're making another
doom they might go to like uh what's
doom
what's the other game that people always
be talking about
there's another game that's that's kind
of like doom that people think that
they're going to make and if they make
that
then they can still use that type of
template and use it obviously adjust it
arcane i want to dishonor three
that's what i want
i want to dishonor three
i hope i get it
machine guns they're making indiana
jones
i kind of want a wolfenstein three from
them
i know they just started indiana jones
so hopefully maybe they made wolfenstein
three between
uh the time because i have they just
been sitting around doing nothing all
these years
i'm hoping not i'm hoping they have
something
it's hard to yeah quake thank you flame
quake
machine guns i hope they have something
i'm not saying that you know
they have to make a wolf inside three
but i really hope they do because i know
a lot of people like that franchise
roundhouse studio brand new studio we've
never seen nothing of it so i'm sure
we'll probably see something from that
next year uh
so let's go over the game
that we'll probably see the most of
quicker
343 industries gonna be making halo
probably this entire generation we might
see something from them at the end of
the generation that's not halo wise but
i would assume that 343 is going to make
halo the majority of this generation
world's edge
probably will pick up a new ip on top of
age of empires
hey addict undead labs has
waiting yeah
we'll get to that here in a second okay
world's edge i think they'll pick up
something else besides age of empire
maybe make an age of empire type of game
in like maybe a gears universe or a halo
universe or something like that i don't
think they're going to work on age of
empire the entire generation coalition i
think they're going to make this small
game gears 6
and then they're going to make a new ip
after gears i think after gear 6 gears
is gonna be put up on the shelf for a
while that's just my opinion
compulsion
we might see this game
next year turns the gameplay might come
out the year after i don't know
we'll have to see how this is this is a
pending question got a lot of faith in
compulsion games i feel like people are
sleeping on them but we have to see them
actually come out devil finds a wild
card they can make whatever the hell
they want because people respect that
company
they actually have a game called massive
challenge that i really enjoy that i
hope that they revisit i doubt it highly
doubt they'll put
they'll make a massive challenge too but
i really liked massive chalice and i
would really like if they made that game
xbox game studio publishing
this could be anything you guys know how
that is
the initiative making they're gonna make
a perfect dart maybe a perfect dark too
at the end of the generation i think
we'll see perfect dart probably next e3
maybe next video game awards because
clearly they've been really putting a
lot of emphasis behind the video game
awards and i could see
perfect dark coming out 2023
i don't know
uh exile don't expect anything from the
studio for a long time
uh i don't think was because they
literally just made wasteland so i would
say
you probably won't see their new game as
far as like a reveal maybe to like 2023
you'll see a reveal and then maybe 2024
you'll see gameplay maybe it'll come out
that year i don't know though
i don't know how
far along they are in that game
mojang studios i love that they did
something else besides minecraft but i
know minecraft is a huge moneymaker and
they're probably not going to do
anything besides minecraft and i have to
respect them for it because minecraft is
a lot of money that is to be made
ninja theory hellblade2 and another ip
for uh well they're making a lot of
stuff but i'm talking about like in
terms of their big stuff
i i would expect hellblade 2 to
not be their only game they make this
generation i hope not
they didn't get the initiative
ninja theory probably
took the hit the most because of the
pandemic because they do a lot of mocap
and i feel like there's got to be
a lot of
time they lost because of mocapping for
during the pandemic
uh obsidian about
beginning of 2023 i think we'll see game
play next e3
uh obsidian i think that will come out
the beginning of 2024.
uh i don't think people realize how far
the outer worlds 2 is i don't think it's
nearly as as
in early stages as people think plague
against fable
2023
maybe 2024.
i don't know
we might see gameplay in 2023 and it
comes out in 2024
i don't know
rare
i don't even know they're gonna keep
building on rare
um i'm not the biggest fan to see these
but i do enjoy playing it with friends
but i don't think it's one of those
things that i would say is like a huge
thing i do think it's like the flagship
title they made last generation because
clearly c ds is a money maker and
they're going to keep supporting that
[ __ ] turn 10
motorsports coming out next year and
then maybe two years after that the next
motorsports i think forza and
motorsports will probably go back to
their every other year thing or maybe
um you know every three years i don't
know
four is it 20 26 i don't think that's i
don't think faye was coming out in 2026.
undead labs 2024 maybe 2025. i don't
know how far along they are in
development when it comes to that game
but there's the game studios star field
obviously next year and then
i would say elder scrolls six will see
gameplay
2023 maybe the game will come out in
2024 2025
i doubt fables next year
i highly doubt fables next year
arcane
i like it dishonored uh i highly doubt
that we'll get one anytime soon uh they
they're making that red fill game or red
fall
i'm i'm gonna reserve my opinions on
that game until i see more about it
but we need to see more about that game
and we need to see what death loop
studio is making after death loop i hope
it's dishonored three i hope microsoft
green lights another dishonored
machine games
i would like machine games to help other
studios
because i feel like they they're
talented studios i think microsoft they
need more
support studios i think uh
neither buy some support studios or turn
some of these into support studios maybe
like i'm not talking about like more
than one like clearly they can work on
their game but like have half the studio
as a support studio for the rest of the
uh
developers and the other half work on a
game because i do feel like we really
they really need help there's a lot of
studios here
they need at least one support studio
like to me all of these are competent
studios that would not be a support
studio even machine games the only
reason i'm saying machine games is
because you know they work on a a lot
more closed narrative
focused games so i think that maybe
theirs take a little less to make but i
don't know anything about development so
that might be completely inaccurate but
i feel like
you know maybe
hire a couple or make a couple support
studios from from the ground up
i feel like that's that's the best way
to do
um pray to i wasn't the biggest fan of
pray
roundhouse duty i think we'll probably
see something by them next to e3 they've
been working on a game for a while i
just don't know what they'll be working
on
and what's crazy you guys like
all these games
yeah uh indiana jones 2024 sounds about
right
that's a lot of games guys and that's
not to mention the little indies that
they be getting in game pass all the
time like
anyone
that says microsoft isn't going to
compete this generation
really not paying attention
like you're really not paying attention
i don't think you guys realize how much
microsoft is investing into this
platform
and they're going to do some they're
going to do some numbers man i really do
i really and truly believe this year has
been a good year for by xbox and i don't
even think it was a good good year like
i think this year as good as a year as
it has been for xbox it's going to be
a filler year compared to what years in
the future xbox is going to have
uh microsoft studios and redmond is a
support then they're fine then i just
feel like i would like for them to have
like a support studio or two
yeah i don't people don't realize like
they're going to come out swinging and
when i mean swinging
they're going to come out swinging and i
miss people they're going to hit people
left and right
i mean if you think that dylan
that that's cute
like all i know is i mean if you want to
take it there when we can take it there
playstation what is playstation doing
after
horizon and god of war
because playstations games take three to
five years to make
xbox is going to have [ __ ] every year
high quality every year
playstation's gonna have probably the
best games on the market still
but at the end of the day does that
matter when you don't have consistent
stuff to play
i don't think it does i think people are
going to play playstation 5 to play
playstation games but in terms of what
you're going to be playing the most
people are going to start gravitating
towards the xbox brand because they're
going to be on the xbox most
sure playstation's still going to be
bought playstation games is going to be
bought but it's not going to be one of
those things where people
oh that's fine dylan but it's not going
to be one of those things where people
are going to be they're going to feel
like they have to play it 24 7 because
right now i feel like
25 games develop means nothing to me
dylan a
hardhead hates when i talk positive
about xbox
uh final fantasy 16 i'll give you that
spider-man 2 i'll give you that
wolverine i'll give you that couture
i don't know
yeah i can give you that uh saint
monica's working on
that's probably early in development
maybe six months to a year in people
don't realize too how much the pandemic
has slowed stuff down
uh factions like okay let's go over
all right let's let's go over these okay
final fantasy 16 that's a
2023-2022 game most likely 2023 because
we still ain't seen no solid gameplay
from final fantasy and we haven't seen
it in a couple events so that makes me
think that they're going to show it next
year and it's coming out the year after
i might be wrong but that's what i think
spider-man 2 2023 2024 game if we see
gameplay next year at their event
caliber that's on e3 level then i will
give you a 2023 release date on
spiderman but until we see that gameplay
next year i can't say it's coming out
next year
we'll say god of war god of war we still
haven't seen no gameplay whatsoever so
that makes me think that they're going
to show game play well we've seen
gameplay but not like that in-depth
stuff that we're used to so it makes me
think that next year what we're going to
end up seeing is we're going to see that
in-depth thing with the release date
saying that it's coming out in 2023
that's just my opinion
and wolverine that's 2024 2025. 2025
i don't see
i don't see wolverine coming out
anytime soon and factions too will come
out eventually i'll give you that but
it's just hard to tell when that will
come out
i don't call people playstation rats you
know they
i don't know man god of war
is definitely a solid experience but
i'mma probably
okay so the entire slate has no gameplay
where's the
the difference between xbox and
microsoft and uh xbox and sony and it's
not anything good i do think sony does
this better is i can expect to see game
play later on through the year
and they still release starfield in the
holiday because they they're known to do
that i they don't sony doesn't normally
do that they don't normally release
stuff in the holiday season they usually
end it around september october they
don't usually go anything past that and
sometimes they don't even go near those
dates so to me
and like are they going to show it at
their e3 event which would be in like
june july and then release the games
three or four weeks later
like when are they realistically going
to say the release date for for god of
war
if that wasn't at the video game awards
you know i guess it might be at some
event but once again if it is at a
random state of play which i don't think
they do that they normally
try to advertise that state of play for
a couple for at least a week to two so
they could easily do that i'll give you
that heartache hardhead but to me
the part that i don't understand is
they usually don't do release dates
that early into the year sometimes they
will depending on what kind of game it
is but it's like i said horizon zero or
horizon forbidden west i said the same
thing on iron lore's podcast multiple
times that we haven't seen nothing on
horizon forbidden west and i think it's
a 2022 game and people clowned on me
saying it wasn't and guess what it ended
up being a 2022 game
we probably will see like
a
a review like we'll probably see some
kind of announcements next year
for
uh final fantasy vii remake too
i don't think i don't think god of war
is coming out next year you know maybe
i'm wrong but i don't think it is
i don't think it is we got 103 people in
here man hit that like button hit that
like button i know this is uh you know
most of the time you guys know that the
show's coming i usually promote it the
night before the night uh the morning of
uh but today was like spontaneous and i
appreciate you guys coming through
yeah death loop will be on xbox next
year but at that point uh justin spa i
don't think that matters like we can't
really give props for
getting a timed exclusive that another
platform got like one final fantasy vii
uh remake if it ever comes out for play
uh xbox like are we going to give
them props for getting something that
they should have had from the start i
would like that they would be there but
to me i want them to be there more
consistently hustle i didn't contact
hustle because it was so late
into the day and i want and i told
hustle that he could you know the rest
of the year is a uh
is
is good like i didn't want to bother him
uh september october maybe
i mean it's possible but i just i feel
like we would see more on god of war by
now but let me ask you guys a question
besides all that because we're about to
end this right here pretty soon
what
i have considered putting a third seat
into this show into the attic show
three me
hustle
and a mystery person
who would you guys feel like has good
chemistry and good energy to be this
third seat who do you think will be this
third seat i actually reached out to kid
smooth to be this third seat
um he's got a lot going on so i doubt
he'll be he'll do it but i i want a
third seat to have better chemistry
between me and hustle i won't go over
three
i'll never go over three and the fourth
one will be a rotating guess sometimes i
do got a lot of guests plan to come on
the attic show next year though i'm
gonna probably try to get more
developers on here too because i
actually know a lot of developers
so i'm kind of curious on what you guys
think that i should do in terms of
putting on this channel
and and making this a panel
for the attic show snowball mike uh
i'm pretty sure he's not gonna
come in
this show
like he would be a guest i'm pretty sure
he can be a guest but i doubt snow bike
snow bike mike would be a panel member
keep in mind i said panel member i
didn't say guest
dealer gaming he's got his own podcast
and the exact same day that attic show
is taking place
j dubs
i don't know
that that's a mystery i'd like to get
jade up but sometimes jw
i'm reading the chat guys i'm reading
the chat
i'm kind of curious
erica i'd like to get erica that would
actually be a good choice but
um she's on the
she's on the west coast that'd be really
hard to do
uh fonzarelli
um i he he's he's definitely a good
guest a good guest but i don't know i
tried to get fonzarelli
to be
on the show before i reached out to
hustle
but that didn't work out so well for me
because he's always so busy
ran has his own show
i don't think he would ever do that
um i got no problem with crap gamer but
i don't think i would actually
put crab gamer on the show we just have
different visions on what content
is
zalker that'd be cool
invite mbg
no
a female would be great
there's just not a lot of female
in the community man
and it's not necessarily i got to find
one that has good chemistry between me
and hustle and that could be difficult
erica would be a great choice but
erica is on the west coast and that
would be hard unless i moved
the podcast up
in time which i don't want to do that
okay mega that's that's good i like k
megan
flip
uh keno developers they make a plan for
xbox for after they take a break
they should just pay someone to to do
the port they clearly made so
bring someone new
the thing about the new thing is i'd
have to rotate the new people out over
and over again until i find someone good
uh i don't mind bringing in people
established but brand new off the law is
really hard to do because it's hard to
find people that really resonate with
the people already on the panel the good
thing about that is to just mean hustle
so it's not hard you know it's not as
hard but it's still a difficult thing to
do
i would like kids smooth me and kid
smooth have known each other for years
and we have the best chemistry i know
out of the majority of people i'm pretty
sure he would work pretty good with um
with hustle
uh ashlyn lucas she
she works i don't know if i think she's
on the east coast i don't know
so you know
i would like tim dawg i am going to get
tim dawg as a guest i don't think 10 dog
10 dog does a lot and he does a podcast
on tuesdays he does rdx i don't know if
he would be willing to come on like that
uh miles i've asked miles multiple times
to come on the attic show
uh always schedule conflicts so
you know
after i asked you
two or three times i'm pretty much done
asking you at that point you know
clearly you know he's a busy dude i i
can't you know
i keep trying
but if someone's that busy there's just
nothing i could do about it
you know he does a lot over there at
windows central
and i have a really weird time frame
that makes it hard for people to get on
um
forte i like forte but forte does enough
man
keep at it too then if you can't get
smooth i'm trying to get smooth man i'm
trying i'm trying to get smooth
i'd like to get smooth
what i'm probably going to do is start i
know jeff grubb's going to come on
sometime next year
i appreciate bacon life
bacon life i'm trying to get
i'm trying to get uh
i know jeff grubb's gonna come on i'm
gonna reach out to snow bike mike
uh acg is eventually gonna come on he's
been really busy here lately uh but i do
want him to get him on here
um i know some people don't like
dreamcast guy but i get a lot of people
i get why people have issues with them
sometimes he's a very outspoken
individual but i'm an outspoken
individual so i can't really
attack someone for having you know a
very
open
agenda like not necessarily gender
that's a bad word it's a bad phrase to
say like a very
vocal voice that you don't care if it
offends people and i feel like a lot of
people have issues with dreamcast guy
but i'm not one of those people i feel
like he's a very
good content creator and he is he's
vocal sometimes man but we're all vocal
i mean you guys would make it very clear
you don't like him in the chat so
it's okay i feel like at that point you
know it's anyone's ball game
but you know
probably gonna end this here
i don't know how i went for two hours
i have no clue how i went for two hours
i was gonna stream something but
i'm gonna keep the attic show and the
streaming thing separate
uh keep in mind i will be moving
everything
streaming wise to twitch
so if you want
to follow the twitch channel
definitely go over there uh we're gonna
be doing more uh iop lords let's plays
there like me and king need to finish at
text two but i think being cog might
play it takes two because i mean cog
doesn't really play a whole lot of games
together because of our weird scheduling
issues so we might try to play that for
a couple streams on
the um on the xbox because i really like
it takes two it definitely deserves game
of the year but you know i definitely
appreciate it for coming through
uh you know you guys made my birthday
great this year with all the all the
comments and stuff that you guys did on
twitter you know
i was in a lot of pain on my birthday
you know it kind of went away there
towards like one-ish that's when i went
to like watch spider-man and stuff
but uh
you guys make it a lot easier man you
make uh
youtube has definitely been a very
highlight of my life sure it's been a
negative too sometimes you guys be me
getting me to go over and and cuss
people out you know i've been trying to
do better on that
um
but
sometimes
i fell at it you know
trying to do better on that
but you know i appreciate everyone for
coming through i understand some some
playstation people in the chat arguing
with some xbox people it's gonna happen
just keep it respectful i won't really
say too much as long as you ain't
calling people some crazy stuff i don't
really care if you guys bicker with each
other just make sure it's respectful
because we don't want that type of chat
we want to chat people feel like they
can say you know anything within reason
because i do feel like if you say some
off the wall stuff the chat will come on
you but as long as you're not
disrespectful it's okay just don't call
people personal names
you know
even christopher hart feels comfortable
in iop and i want the attic shows chat
to feel similar but you know i
appreciate ever coming through this